what now
off back up crack some heads open drag
the bodies inside
[Music]
anything
no this trouble the net around me
you won't you know it i lost everything
let me be plain again solve your own
problems clean up your own [ __ ]
go [ __ ] yourself be careful who you
bargain with
wanted to talk it's okay
hmm not here not there who are you
name's v and what is it you want v
all these years it's really her
[ __ ] rogue just kicking it back on a
couch at the afterlife
don't mess with her she's got mri's
right through you
what was her gripe why didn't you ask
her might still be around
sniveling in a corner need your services
gotta track a guy down mm-hmm anders
hellman
hotshot engineer worked for arisaka
milisek
anders hellman pinpoint him for me
thanks jump in too soon first
my help's got a price second and third
dexter desean jackie wells tipa
multiple bells ring and b left a lot of
bodies behind
death walks in your wake chalk that up
to bad luck
there's the [ __ ] i know ask her about
soccer tower how they shot me up right
in front of her
want to go through obits really fine
johnny silverhand zeroed inside our
soccer tower
before your very eyes got more if you
want
or we could just talk got balls on you
boy
don't like that on everybody but they
seem to suit you
anyways feelings be damned i've always
said
this is pure biz you need my help so get
those eddies ready
see should be enough
come back tomorrow we'll talk
[Music]
um
here to see rogue expecting me
hey rogue i'm back what about hellman
two please make some room
sit down i hope you found him
don't see that often determination like
yours
must really need this guy matter of life
and death
i haven't heard that for a while either
to your health to yours kid
gonna need it
thanks nix
queen of the afterlife who would have
thunk
got a shard for you intel interesting
stuff
let's see what you got
your helmet's not on any payroll not
officially anyway
but he does pop up in gmt's confidential
stacks
it's a kang tao subsidiary chinese court
hang tao's been using them as a fig leaf
for years their mask for more sensitive
operations
all that clear
think you can drag him down getting a
mark on him ought to be easy
actually grabbing him another story
entirely
decrypted map of upcoming kang tao
convoy roots
think hellman might be in one of them
thing is which one
take a look at the specs on this one a
lone av no ground support
no linked cargo manifests either weird
sure kang tao sometimes transports stuff
unregistered if they want to push it
under the table
but catch the load on the saving already
approved in the system
but too low so definitely no cargo on
board
huh but there's a passenger list
kang tao security detail plus one vip
transfer from chanting our boy helmet
that was the good news there it is
so what's the bad news bad news is the
extraction site
look night city airspace
all this no way to jack the transport
that the ncpd picking up on
and here we're too close to kang tao we
even give that av a dirty look
their backup hustle will be on us but
right here's jackson plains narrow
corridor just outside the city
and just out of kangtal's reach guess
it's your lucky dead
dead zone i'll grab them there
gonna need a native to the area someone
who'll set up the op
cobbled together the gear
so a native know any hick mercs
just one pan am palmer
she can't count on her clan anymore but
she's a true nomad
she knows those lands and she will help
you
you won't have a choice won't have a
choice does not sound enticing
not for her not for me enticing comes at
a price you can't possibly afford
can't possibly afford to blow this
chance at nab and helmet
your operation your call got a bad
feeling fee
why's pan am got to help me i sense a
catch
pretty big one occasionally pan am moves
merch for me
last job well it wasn't a good day for
her
she run into a hitch complete bust
actually
lost the goods and her right pan am will
do anything to get the load back
means her dignity i know her
okay guess i can try to help her if we
don't know where to look i mean
we do i do
fine let me hear what you know rocky
rich
ghost town just outside night city pan
am knows where
you'll go there get the merch back
wheels too
naturally you'll call her first sending
you her deeds
now finally let's get out of here
all clear thanks good luck
oh [ __ ] not good
hey pan am got your name from rogue
name's v great where's that old warhorse
wanna kick me now
[Music]
forget robron i want to help oh very
kind but it's far too little far too
late
so do tell rosh you can eat my shorts
tell it to your therapist
calling about your ride and the merch
you lost interested
or are you gonna tell me to eat your
shorts too
the royal freight yard on bonita street
the one hugging the city line
we'll meet there see you
hey interested in some work
doing what a business opportunity cargo
transport
good from a to b quick and quiet
interested
game it's simple you go to the kabuki
waterfront
collect the package give me a call then
i tell you how to deliver it
very straightforward yeah everything
except my pay
don't worry there's a bonus in it for
you imported and duty-free
duty-free and detail-free yes but all
together fair
it's a simple job generously
compensating
yeah sure i mean good
located
on the way
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
uh
hey pan am so you're v
where's my
agree to help me you'll find out oh [ __ ]
no
you will not jerk me around tell me
where my car is
hey come on calm down don't tell me what
to do
fine know where to find the cargo and
your car
you go alone you won't get him back and
you could lose something else
besides so let's figure something out
what do you want
[Applause]
need to hit a kang tower transport won't
be easy wanna know i can count on you
are you out of your goddamned mind about
you or the job
kangta's av root will take it over
jackson planes
heard that should help us yeah i doubt
it
gonna be a guy on board need to talk to
him
[ __ ] in return and phone your cargo
helping getting back what's yours
we got a deal
i don't know i [ __ ]
all right deal but if you want your
thing done we'll need to get my thornton
back
first so where is it
cars in rocky ridge you're supposed to
know where that is
cars there goods are there nash you dirt
eating bastard
i will strangle you
now should chew me yours he hang you out
to dry do not call him that
fine partner former
if ever the ship tricked me
straightened into my truck and emerged
probably now aims to sell it off in
rocky ridge
is he ever going to be [ __ ]
disappointed
rocky ridge let's go hang on
i i should think this through
[ __ ] yes we'll need backup
we have one brief stop to make on the
way wanna tell me where
give me a sec i should call the client
convince them to leave the bastard
hanging
going ahead with the deal behind rogue's
back
brave i guess more [ __ ] dumber than a
drum
buzz hey now she's gonna pass you the
merch in rocky ridge
the thing is the [ __ ] screwed me
over
buzz i will take care of it i just need
you to give me a chance
buzz come on how many times have i moved
things for you
and how many times have i failed
you have my word after dark
okay no don't call off the meat just
don't show up
i'll take care of everything do you even
have to ask
of course i will thanks boss you won't
regret this
okay i have bought us some time
boz vista del rey buys i had no idea you
drive for sixth street
is that not allowed no nothing wrong
with it they still wild about stars
stripes and core heartland values
ah strong word wild and i don't care
they pay well
it's simple so
where to now the aldi caldo camp
i need to see some of the old clan don't
seem too excited
that's not your concern i still have
friends there
good let's roll get in
where'd you get the ride straight out of
some driveway and rancho
yes exactly is that a problem for me
no not at all i mean there's no
accounting for taste
screw you
how the hell did you land in this mess i
like the color the air freshener and
boosters that came extra
you know i don't mean the car what am i
supposed to tell you
that i'm not about to let my partner rob
me and get away with it
that my fixer made me look like a
goddamn fool
what about you why do you need that
clown from the av
this particular clown's got intel i need
i'm running out of time to get it
so why didn't she tell me she knew about
nash broke
you better not to wonder what her agenda
might be
goddammit
brogues queen of the afterlife plays her
pawns as she pleases
did you just call me a pawn i got a good
looker
she rose to the top because she reads
people so what if she keeps things to
herself
it's a skill in her profession well i
think she's a lying manipulative [ __ ]
she put me together with that rapping
did you know that
must have had her reasons you don't say
rogue won't open her mouth without
weighing the foreign against
but to spill in one
well would you look what the cat dragged
in
is that a ghost or is it just my
hangover
[ __ ] you too mm-hmm
who's this my babysitter me this is
scorpion
mitch two old friends
well might not have needed a babysitter
if you hadn't lost the merchant the car
shut it b are you kidding
did that beauty thornton of yours
finally bite it she
wrote it to death in old night city nah
it got clipped
[ __ ] who did it doesn't matter i'll get
her back
that's why i'm here
need your help with what
what's this about ref and screwed pan am
plan is to show them that was a bad idea
how bad did they get you bad enough to
make me sit quietly through all your
[ __ ]
you know we would do anything for you
sister
but now that was hard seriously
you won't help well the old man told us
to
sit tight and get those generators back
up after the batteries went kaput
generators you won't help because of
some goddamn generators
is this another joke
really could use your help
not this time we're needed here [ __ ] i
don't believe this
so you'll stay put because saul told you
to you couldn't care less about me
pan am this isn't about saul
it's about the clan you know that listen
we can't leave camp no chance but but
soul never said a thing about gear
okay well i'll need that rifle of yours
and some of my own stuff take whatever
you want
and take care of yourself out there yeah
thanks guys i'll grab the gear then be
out of your hair
looks like you're stuck with me mm-hmm
you disappointed i don't know
maybe a little yes
hey pan am are you staying away no i'll
be going again soon
we'll talk next time
hey panda
have you brought someone new does saul
know
not your concern friend
will you help me with this
what's inside a few odds and ends that
should be useful
take it all right that's everything
let's go
you figure out your differences with
soul when you come back
you'll stop by later right honey next
time ellie i promise
so i'm off yeah yeah go on go already
call us sometime keep an eye on our v
put it in the trunk
we can go hop in
seems you got a real problem with
authority what
rogue saul your leader
their leader seemed in a hurry to dealt
with the hell out of there
let's just say saul wouldn't have been
happy to see me what happened
the reason we came to california was
because he promised to change for the
all decaldoes
he claimed we would turn over a new leaf
but you saw it
we got a handful of tents on a heap of
sand
a hell of a promised land i wanted
something different
better saul's a damned coward he'll be
the end of the clan
i'm certain
mitch and scorpion seen good souls the
best friends a girl could ask for
i'd stay in the camp too if i were in
their shoes [ __ ] saul and his generators
of course
yet the clown comes first but i'm not
part of it anymore
still treated you like you're one of
them they care about you
do you have anyone you would call close
i haven't been so lucky
i see
were those two in the army scorpion
mitch yeah
panzer boys they're on contract during
the last four
panzer boys flew those huge transporters
scorpion piloted mitch ran security they
both got some kick-ass combat implants
and a stack of really [ __ ] up
nightmares
so rocky ridge empty dusty hole in the
middle of [ __ ] nowhere i heard
natives either moved to night city or
just got the hell out
then you know almost all there is to
know the whole area was waiting on a new
interstate extension
i was supposed to breathe new life into
the town
it didn't happen of course how many
ghost towns you think are there
hundreds country-wide thousands
i drove down i-80 the other day all you
have to do is pull over after sundown
it's quiet then i can hear it what's
that
the wind whistling through boarded up
windows tumbleweeds scratching across
dry sandy tracks that's how towns die
not with a bang but with whispers and
whimpers
okay we have arrived
[Music]
what do we do we get ready to greet the
raffins
and we have little time for that we'll
need to improvise
we should scout first to look for
anything that might be useful
[Music]
[Music]
that rocky ridge could be any deader
everything's down
nothing works here
well have you found anything
no dice nothing's up all cut off
well we'll make it work the raffins will
roll in after dusk
we will have a surprise ready for them
we just need to get some power flowing
let's check the substation okay
hmm
[Music]
found the breakers but there's no juice
on them not to worry
come down i know how to surprise the
bastards
right so the intersection is powered
from that transformer substation right
the switch gear on the roof will flip
the switch there and everything will
light up like christmas
understood
fine idea let's get us some power i'll
look around for access points
great they're likely to show up in
numbers we can't know how many
we need to out fox them then get to my
car somehow relax
got a few ideas i'll try to play a
little game with them at the
intersection
hell yes perfect as soon as they see the
lights they'll have to check who
why and how nova yep first we start up
the control terminal below
the gear on the roof is a hunk of junk
without it come on we'll give it a boost
from the car battery
that should do the trick wait for me by
the substation
i'll bring the car around
[Music]
the panel looks to be in good shape i'll
make a bypass circuit to the power
supply
that should do it we'll just have to get
it up and running
grab the jumper cables from the trunk
we'll boost it from the car battery
red cable connected give me a moment i
need to hook everything up here
i'm done now the black rattler
there she goes but the old jalopy served
us well
okay i've got voltage start the terminal
inside and once the power is on in the
building
get on that roof you got it i'll set up
on the tower
we'll have the whole intersection on the
platter
yes ma'am
switchgear's got power prime we'll have
some fun at the intersection
let's get into position
now we wait
remember as soon as we see them you give
us power
got it cover me just in case of course
they're rolling in my thorn you see her
really really hard to miss
let's take them by surprise let's try to
do this quietly
if anything happens i'll start picking
them off sound good sounds great
so
[Music]
the show starts now
let there be light
grab the car shot the driver has it this
look deserted to you
[Music]
for the girl with a mohawk
all right
[Music]
covering your
so
[ __ ] me that hurt
come on
let's pack it in
wait for me in the car
[Music]
move i'll take the wheel
sure sure leave the driving to the pros
at last
and she's prime wheels isn't she dreamy
indeed
no surprise you wanted her back she
completes me
see managed just fine without mitch and
scorpion
listen v it's not over yet it's not you
got the cargo you got your car
i did not get nash who was not in rocky
ridge
the [ __ ] didn't show
pan am listen i have a plan and i don't
care
the car and the merch that's what we
were after we got him
six street awaits worth it tonight
listen to me for [ __ ] sake
i know where their little hidey hole is
we'll take the old unfinished freeway
nearby
they will not be expecting us i'm sure
of it
all right so where's this hideout i'll
hop and skip away
thanks fee what nash did
i placed my trust in him he was the
first person i worked with after leaving
the elder caldes
after i came to night city and i granted
him my trust
i get it know how you feel
had someone betray me just like that
once and did you make them pay
never got the chance someone else got to
him first
but if they had it would you have done
it
no doubt that's skipping a beat
let's get this over with
[Music]
are you ready let's get him
let it slide
um
zero
let's go
goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
finally
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
fun
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
careful
come on take that position
[Music]
hello bro what did you say again
solve your own problems clean up your
[ __ ]
is dead one [ __ ] cleaned and the sixth
street merch
nash can't deliver it anymore but if you
ask nicely
i might be able to help you help me
i take my cut up front honey but i guess
i'm touched was actually wondering if
you wouldn't forget about this while
you're out chasing down a vendetta
so feel any better maybe a little
let's get out of here
one bitter cold [ __ ] that broke think
she might have lost the plot mean to say
she used to be sweet and alluring
never that but she's no stranger to the
other end of the stick
then she might need a nice strong shock
hey boss got your cargo
no no fast ones come on let's meet
sunset motel
i know you're not kidding i'm certain to
be there
okay i arranged our meeting let's do the
deal and start working on helmand
agreed should be fun
no at least i don't think so
hey boss panna how's nash
doesn't seem to be answering his phone
don't call him anymore
there's no need you got balls girl
what's this a bonus of some sort
we work together hmm change tunes like
you change clothes
girl there first-class merch
so everything's in order check your
account
should be pretty plush in a couple of
minutes it's been a pleasure
but i believe rogue's the one who is to
payment you're all right
think you earned a tip let's roll
that one well come on
let's get a drink
raffan's wiped six streets pleased
pretty good day for pan am palmer
good day's not over yet you still have a
chance to piss me off
oh i i can't
hello noah hey new biz or new friends
back there
take a wild guess is everything good
with you
did those bozos come around again
raffins
nah it's been quiet they'll be back sure
enough
this place has seemed worse what can i
get you
brosif two of them so that package for
street
what was it you didn't peak valoperidol
drugs for the cyber psychos in our midst
they trade in
yes they have deals with black clinics
rippers
cheers used to what's yet to come
to what's to come
another one over here
thanks noah cheers let me know if you
need anything else
think he'll ever go back i mean not
right now but
someday i don't rightly know on the one
hand
i don't have anyone outside the clan
[ __ ] i don't really know any other life
but on the other without my clan who am
i
who would i become if i stayed in night
city
could you start over again that's what i
did
for now i only seem to be really good at
burning bridges talking about rogue
no but thanks for reminding me
v do you think i can make a fresh start
with her too
she seems to better eddie's on the right
people
you'll work it out
the raffins we done with them oh no
the shiver cockroaches one's never rid
of them
but it should be quiet for a time
they'll need to gather their wits and
dust themselves off
all right time we look to my needs
what's the plan for helmand
i've come up with a plan a first draft
but i need to sleep on it
work it out then we can talk about the
details
i think your best to rent rooms here
just to stay in the area
we'll get to work around midnight it'll
help keep us out of sight
agreed
maybe we rent just one room good idea
noah has two twin beds in every room
we'll save some money
not quite what i had in mind
what did you have in mind just um
glad to have met you so i thought
i'm glad we met too that could have been
a damn tough day
but thanks to you it all went well maybe
calls for a little celebration
sure we can celebrate
but not today i'm beat
no one will need a room twin beds just
for tonight
i'll go catch a few wings
ugh i'm starting to feel that stress go
away
i'll probably be out as soon as i hit
the sack
you had better get some rest too that's
the plan this is only the beginning
good night
i'm gonna puke